Could I get two glasses
of Tempranillo, please?
It is very, very bad luck
to open a bottle of wine
and not finish it.
Do you do this a lot?
Do what?
Pick up sad and confused
women in the farthest
reaches of Little Haiti.
Only ones as gorgeous
and interesting as you.
I've got a lot
of things going on.
I just want to
get to know you.
I've been getting
these blackouts.
I'm left with this really
strange sense of déjà vu.
I keep seeing myself
die over and over.
You're safe.
You're here with me.
It feels like I'm
not seeing all of you.
You know everything about me.
Do I?
We're definitely seeing an
acceleration of memory loss.
I just think I can really help
you through this transition,
sweetheart.
What if I could give
you the perfect life
that you always wanted?
Wouldn't you want that?
I need some time to think.
I just hope you figure it
out before it's too late.
She'll do anything to keep you.
The blackouts.
The headaches.
They're only getting
worse, right?
I feel like I'm
losing my mind.
Why would you do this?
Because we're
meant to be together.
Next time, it's
going to be perfect.